[Music]
hey guys this is katie what this is
katie it is it is it is right
hey guys it's katie and i'm here with my
husband chris hi
and you guys know i've made stuff many
in the past little donuts little pies
but today chris has challenged me to
make something extra special i've been
dreaming of tiny tiny cheeseburgers and
there's a specific kind that you would
like yes it needs to be tiny double
doubles from in and out i've had a
regular cheeseburger from in and out but
i've never had the double double which
is what you always get so i feel like we
should go there
in order double double
this is gonna be a bunch of fun
[Music]
ah we almost died i don't know if you
should be driving all right we're
getting in line can i have two double
doubles two diet cokes thank you
i never drank daika i never drank soda
when you get married
if somebody else if the other person has
a habit that will become your habit
whoa
yes
look at that making a mini version of
this it's a lot of mini layers i'm so
excited
that's great i think this is american
cheese and there's sauce it tastes very
like thousand island it tastes really
healthy
[Music]
kind of feels like we went on a date
that was delicious yes now it's time to
see if i can make that very small what
about if you could hold it like that
that would be good but if i can hold it
if i can just help you're not going to
hold it like that
we'll find out i want to take a nap
i am now ready to make what i think is
the most important part of the mini
burger the buns i don't really think i
can cut corners with this like i thought
about maybe pizza dough i thought about
could i cut out it from already
baked buns no so we're gonna do it from
scratch first thing we need is some
lukewarm water active dry yeast a little
bit of sugar
mix that together
so i'm gonna let this sit for about five
minutes until it's doubled in size it
basically looks like a science
experiment so now we're gonna grab three
and a half cups of flour add some salt
mix that together really quickly and
then we'll add some room temp butter
1 egg
last but not least we'll add our yeast
concoction once it starts to become a
shaggy dough i like to put it out on my
counter and then
bring it together with my hands
and this is where it gets messy it's so
fun to see the transformation of the
dough because at first it's so dry and
shaggy but then as the fats are
incorporated it starts to just transform
to this beautiful soft
smooth dough he's looking like a
beautiful
baby
baby buns i'm going to stop slapping the
dough sorry this guy will put in a bowl
that's been greased and covered with a
towel we're going to leave this for
about an hour until it doubles in size
if i take a little bit longer my house
is cold right now we're just gonna do it
by sight because i guess you know that's
the best way today is all about feelings
[Music]
look at it
i don't know why but this is reminding
me of ghostbusters and like the
marshmallow man it just got so big
next i'll grease the surface a little
bit and we'll just
press it down
and we'll just start cutting out our
little burger buns
oh
just look at that guy he is
so cute add this to a pan with some
parchment on it i am
in love
i think when i'm making things mini i
feel like i'm making a lot of friends so
we'll just repeat this with our
remaining dough now we're going to brush
them with melted butter this is gonna
just give them more flavor and also help
them get that nice golden brown look
the buns are buttered they are done so
now we're gonna go put these in the oven
at 400 degrees for about 7 to 10 minutes
i don't want them to burn but i want
them to be brown wish me luck let's go
put them in
our buns are out of the oven they look
pretty great i'm gonna brush with a
little bit more butter while they're
still hot just to give it a little bit
more glisten a little bit more shine and
more flavor it's like a uh angelic cloud
of buns
ah i love them so much
i love them so much like this
little dude
he's just
he's my best friend they look
great do they taste great that's what
we're gonna find out let's move on to
our next step
we're gonna work on our meat patties so
i've got 80 20 beef here put it on some
parchment
put some parchment over that ladies and
gentlemen and we're gonna roll it out
but kind of like a large patty
this looks good let's
[Music]
meet
lots of meat
gross so now that our meat is prepared
i'm gonna cut out just a bunch of meat
patties not great looking so i'm gonna
roll them into a ball that seems about
the right size i've never done this
before so who knows what the right size
is but
that seems like a perfect little ball of
meat
so next i'm just going to keep cutting
out meat patties rolling them into balls
and setting them on our sheet pan all
our little meat babies are done
and they are weirdly cute and gross at
the same time we're gonna cook these up
in a little bit but let's move on to our
next steps and we'll put this in the
fridge
okay it is time to make the special in
and out sauce which i think is pretty
close to like a thousand island dressing
so we're gonna combine some mayo some
ketchup to that relish a little bit of
sugar and white distilled vinegar
well the color is looking pretty close
now it's time to prep little itty bitty
toppings for our burgers
[Music]
so for our onions i'm going to use
shallots which are actually so flavorful
and really a little bit sweeter for the
cheese i went to the deli counter and i
got some american cheese slices so the
burger patties were about two
centimeters i'm gonna cut the cheese
about as big next we're gonna cut
tomatoes the smallest tomatoes i could
find are cherry tomatoes which are
delicious i think they could upgrade the
taste last thing i'll do is chop up some
iceberg lettuce just like i did the
cheese to make squares
so to cook our burgers we're going to
heat up some butter
the best way to do it is to
cook them on some butter the next part
i'm gonna have to move very quickly i'm
gonna put the burgers on top add some
foil and use this cast iron pan to help
smash them down and stop them from
curling this is an experiment i've never
done this so
if it doesn't work it's okay i've got
more patties
okay
oh look at her little baby baddies all
right we're gonna flip all our bat oh
oh i flip one i unflip the other
basically i only need two good ones
squeeze them down do these look
proportionate to the burger yeah okay
cool so now we add our little cheesies
on top we're gonna
put a lid on so the moisture can and the
heat can help that cheese melt it's been
about 30 seconds let's check them
they're so cute
i
need to calm down and get them off
without wrecking them
oh no i'm going to finish the rest of
these off and then we are going to
assemble i'm so excited
all right it is the moment of truth it's
the part of every time i make something
mini that i dread just a little bit but
also love i've already cut the little
buns and they actually turned out
perfect they're a little hard on the
outside but nice and soft on the inside
let's do this now the double double
starts with some sauce then it goes
tomato
then lettuce patty oh god then onion
patty
this is so tall it's a lot of mini
layers and then
the top
that
is ridiculous
oh my god i'm gonna not i'm gonna make a
okay i'm gonna make
a single
so i may not have achieved a perfect
double double but i definitely made a
cute little cheeseburger and at the end
of the day didn't chris just want mini
cheeseburgers so i'm gonna make a bunch
of single burgers and we'll see
if he's cool then
[Music]
it's not going to be
what you expected what
here you go
open your eyes whoa
these look amazing they're not double
doubles oh they're single they're ready
to mingle
i can guess why maybe it was too tall
it was what i feared from the beginning
it was like too much they're actually
smaller than i thought you were gonna
make like i said in a car i want to fit
it on one finger basically sits on one
finger what's the most important thing
though is does it taste like just an
in-and-out burger
it actually just tastes like i took one
bite of the burger we have this morning
i'm not to like toot my own horn but it
really does take a full-size burger and
divide it into eight then you've got
eight tiny ones and they're really great
all right bye guys thanks for watching
let us know in the comments what other
things you want us to make minnie or
chris is just going to keep requesting
it yeah
and he's a madman i am crazy
[Music]
you